bien
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa combatir noticias
falsas en internet será una tarea
difícil en brasil el presidente ayer
bolsonaro emitió una medida provisional
que prohibía las plataformas eliminar
este tipo de contenidos de manera
independiente varias publicaciones del
mandatario han sido borradas en el
pasado por promover desinformación sobre
el kobe 19 según el gobierno ahora esta
medida garantizará la libertad de
expresión pero expertos aseguran que con
la normativa bolsonaro busca seguir
difundiendo información falsa y por
ejemplo sembrar dudas sobre las próximas
elecciones presidenciales si el
resultado no llega a favorecerle
empezamos
mientras la mayoría de países
democráticos presionan a las redes
sociales para que controlen las noticias
falsas que circulan en sus plataformas
en brásil una medida del presidente y el
bolsón ahora parece exigirles todo lo
contrario varias publicaciones del
mandatario y sus seguidores han sido
eliminadas de redes como twitter
facebook o youtube al ser consideradas
falsas o engañosas pero ahora va con la
nueva normativa sólo se permitirá borrar
u ocultar contenido si existe una justa
causa como la promoción del terrorismo y
la incitación a la violencia entre otros
casos enumerados en el documento según
el gobierno esta medida busca defender
la libertad de pensamiento y expresión
en redes sociales pues a su juicio estas
plataformas han limitado las voces
conservadoras la medida provisional
emitida por el gobierno brasileño
prohíbe la remoción de contenidos que
puedan resultar en cualquier tipo de
censura de orden político o ideológico
científico artístico o religioso esta
medida ha sido emitida como resultado de
la preocupación constante por las
acciones tomadas por los grupos de redes
sociales que han sido percibidas como
perjudiciales para el debate saludable
pero a pesar del argumento de bolsonaro
los expertos coinciden en que por el
contrario esta medida supondría un
ataque a la libertad de expresión y
denuncian que en realidad se diseñó para
impedir que las redes sociales retiren
noticias que el propio presidente y sus
partidarios están distribuyendo así lo
dijo a france 24 césar muñoz
investigador senior para las américas de
human right watch y todo ese tipo de
contenido
sería imposible de retirarlo con esta
con esta medida provisional y de hecho
si las plataformas respirará de ese
contenido
recibirían una sanción y el propio
gobierno
ordenaría que fuese restablecido ese
contenido entonces
estamos hablando de unas redes
inundadas que podrían estar inundadas de
noticias falsas más aún de lo que ya
existe y donde el gobierno de jair
bolsonaro tendría la decisión final de
lo que de lo que puede ser dicho al
final ponen en peligro
la libertad de expresarse en las redes
cuando uno solo imaginarse que cuando
uno
se permite
unas declaraciones sin ningún tipo de
moderación por parte de las plataformas
estas van a estar inundadas de robots de
noticias falsas que van a ahogar el
debate legítimo y las discusiones que la
gente pueda tener sobre política pública
human right watch también denuncia que
es contradictorio que el presidente
hable de defender la libertad de
expresión cuando constantemente bloquea
a sus críticos en redes sociales
bolsonaro usa sus cuentas para difundir
información oficial entre los bloqueados
la ong pudo identificar a organizaciones
periodistas y medios de comunicación
human rightswatch argumenta que al
privarlos de ver sus publicaciones el
mandatario está obstaculizando el
trabajo de la prensa y violando el
derecho de acceso a la información
pero volvamos a la normativa aunque ya
está vigente como su nombre lo indica
esta medida es provisional y deberá
pasar por el congreso para convertirse
en ley este tendrá un plazo de máximo
120 días para aprobarla o rechazarla
aunque los medios locales reportan que
un gran número de legisladores se han
articulado para rechazar la normativa y
que incluso han acudido al supremo
tribunal federal de brasil para ello en
medio de la espera a las plataformas
digitales a las que se les dio un plazo
de 30 días para actualizar sus políticas
no han anunciado cambios y sólo se han
limitado a denunciar la normativa esto
dijo facebook brasil al ser consultado
por france 24 esta medida provisional
obstaculiza así efectivamente nuestra
capacidad para limitar los abusos en
nuestras plataformas lo cual es
fundamental para ofrecer un lugar seguro
de expresión y conexión en línea estamos
de acuerdo con los expertos y
especialistas jurídicos que consideran
esta medida una violación de los
derechos constitucionales y es que desde
que llegó a la presidencia y árbol solar
sus círculos se han visto envueltos en
escándalos por la difusión de noticias
falsas o engañosas como promover
milagrosas curas contra el kobe 19
minimizar el impacto de la pandemia y
restarle importancia a las medidas para
prevenir los contagios desde 2019 el
supremo tribunal federal de brasil
investiga una supuesta red de noticias
falsas además de ofensas y amenazas
contra varios jueces que habría sido
gestada por grupos bolsón aristas su
rivalidad con el sistema judicial se
agravó luego de que la corte decidió
incluir al mandatario en esta
investigación tras denunciar que hubo
fraude en las anteriores elecciones
basándose en una serie de vídeos que ya
fueron desmentidos por las autoridades
bolsonaro cuestiona el voto electrónico
que se usa desde 1996 en el país y los
críticos dicen que al igual que el ex
presidente estadounidense donald trump
el líder brasileño está sembrado dudas
en caso de que pierda las elecciones de
2022 veamos ahora qué dicen los
principales medios de comunicación de
brasil sobre esta noticia la revista
ella dice que bolsonaro le da al
ejecutivo el control de las redes
sociales y el poder de cerrarlas
un análisis publicado en el periódico
brasileño folha de sao paulo dice que la
medida de bolsonaro que limita la
eliminación de contenido en internet da
libertad para sabotear el proceso
electoral mientras que el portal g1
titula que según los expertos la medida
puede considerarse inconstitucional el
periódico conservador es tratado también
consultó a expertos que dicen que esta
normativa fomenta la desinformación
hasta aquí y revista digital recuerda
que si quieres repetir esta u otra
visión de nuestro programa lo puedes
hacer a través de nuestra página web
[Música]
www.cuatro.com